I experienced something truly Japanese
the other day gone right gotcha
what gotcha got like best experience in
the weirdest way ever okay so I I rented
a car and there's an option on the
website that was called gacha rent a car
where you just rent a car you have no
[ __ ] clue what car it is and you only
find out when you turn up that sounds
happy yeah so I I always rent the
smallest car anyway because I I I don't
never have much luggage and when I'm
doing video shoots I just need something
that can get three people to a weird
place that a trainer doesn't go to so I
always just rent like a small car like a
Toyota Yaris or something right like a
tiny car fits four people yeah it has
room for bags and stuff and that's
normally like 6 000 Yen just for the car
for the day so it's like it's like 45
bucks so pretty cheap not bad um and
then on the website I saw it was like oh
but for 4 000 Yen so for 30 bucks
basically like not even less than that I
think now you can get a random car for
the day and I thought well it can't be
worse than the yaros like it can't be
worse than the smallest car and so I was
like all right [ __ ] it yeah I'll do it
I'm down so I turned up and I won the
gacha dude did you get the SSR no I
don't get SSR I got a pretty decent I
got a [ __ ] Toyota Prius when I turned
up okay and I was like I'll take a break
I'll take a Prius that's kind of like a
win-win right because if you're always
going if you're if you're always going
for the three star anyway then it's only
going to go up from there right yeah
literally I'm literally pulling for the
most dog [ __ ] thing normally so I'm like
hey if I get what's to say the three
stars the lowest right what if you show
up and it's like here's your bicycle
and then the SSR is like a Lambo right
so I I yeah I think the way it works is
whatever because obviously people bring
cars back I think it's whatever car is
just kind of like awkwardly kind of at
that rent a car someone else doesn't
need it yet so they don't transfer it
you just kind of get it so I'm going to
turn the Prius and I was like oh that's
[ __ ] awesome yeah for Less Price as
well yeah the Prius is normally 100
bucks a day oh hello so I was like
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] dude you got it
but I did have to Google how to uh I was
in the car the Prius had never driven a
Prius before and I couldn't [ __ ] find
the handbrake I was like how the [ __ ] do
I get this the handbrake right so I'm
sitting in the thing and the guy's
asking me like oh you know how to drive
this right yeah
you [ __ ] can't I don't have to drive
it it's a [ __ ] Prius puts it in the
drive it's not moving what the [ __ ] is
it not is it the foot pedal one is it
yeah I've never seen them on these
before Oh really I've literally never
been in the car where it's a foot pedal
uh handbrake yeah and and so I I'm in
the car and the guy the the car hose
with me and my cameraman is like do you
know do you know how to get it out of
the handbrake I was like I have no
[ __ ] clue so I'm like hey Google how
do I get the Prius out of hand handbrake
on and off and then a YouTube video guys
this is really easy oh this is the pedal
at the bottom there's a tiny little
pedal yeah you just push it in and then
it's a handbrake and I was like holy
[ __ ] I've never seen that before yeah my
mom had a Prius sign
have you have you ever seen that before
I've never seen it I've never seen it's
this tiny little hidden thing next to
like where the break is yeah right and
it's just this yeah tiny tiny like like
the [ __ ] size of this [ __ ] and you
just push it in and that's the handbrake
and I was like oh okay but I was great I
mean it was so cheap like with all the
gas and stuff I think the gas was only
like because it's a Prius
it was only like 20 bucks for gas oh
so the whole day the rental car was like
I thought I just paid for a selfie for
myself it's crazy how like because you
know obviously the Train's great in
Japan but there are a lot of occasions
where a car makes way more sense yeah
and so I you know we were going to Fuji
queue which you can get a train robust
you pretty easily but I just want to be
able to go there I wish they would do
that with all public transport you know
just like it's like it's like okay so
you want to get front to this station
take the train gotcha honestly you are
not always train you're going on I feel
like we need more gotcha every aspective
sounds if there was like let's say like
on a plane right there's 30 economy
seats two premium one business yeah and
you can just be like [ __ ] it but it's a
slightly more than economy like it's
slightly more you're like ah [ __ ] it
there's a chance I can tell play the
[ __ ] restaurant hey they should do it
go go to the restaurant and they give
you the menu and be like you can pay for
less but it's gone
wine you could get the Dom Perignon well
you could get or you could get a Capri
Sun
actually like yeah because one of my one
of my favorite restaurants do actually
have like a gacha machine wait you took
me to it yeah yeah weird it's a catcher
when you leave yeah oh really there's
this Italian restaurant uh and if you
spend you know a certain amount of money
you get free pools on this gadget
machine and you can buy you can win
either like a free drink or like a free
meal or a lot of other stuff so I don't
know there's a lot of uh izakayas that
I've been to in Japan uh where it's like
it's kind of it's kind of gotcha but
it's like they use like the dice rolling
game I [ __ ] love that game that's the
Yakuza game right yeah but like it's
like two dice in in a in a bowl yeah and
uh like the one that's near kind of my
house is like you if you buy a beer you
can do chinchiro for it which is where
like depending on what's thrown yeah you
can either get like a bigger price for
the same price or you can get a bigger
price for free or if you get like two
ones then you have to like do five shots
or it's like you know it's just like
it's just this kind of like cool fun
little method to be like all right
listen is that the game they because I I
learned how to play this game after I
watched
um kaiji yeah is it the same game
they're playing kaiji season two that's
just digital oh okay okay I love [ __ ]
it's a good game yeah really really good
game yeah I played it I played in the
bar Pete taught me how to play yeah I
went to a bar in Japan and the owner
would play chinchilla with you yeah yeah
and yeah if you lose I I I I lost some
time so if you lose you had to do the
shot of Jaeger yeah and then and so like
the bar owner lost like three times it
was like three shots of Jaeger it's
pretty fun it's a good game you should
Google how to play it I could explain
but it's it tastes like it's like a few
minutes there's lots of local rules as
well which is yeah basically basically
roll High yeah that's basically it like
get doubles yeah I went to I went to
like a craft beer place the other day
that I had a had a pretty cool system as
well so they you know you can obviously
buy just buy like normal like uh glasses
and normal pints and everything like
that but they also have the system the
special system where
um it's like one price for us like for
like a certain amount of drink right and
then it's kind of like a tier system so
this this drink will always be this one
price but if you can finish your string
you can order more of the same beer but
then the next the next beer you get is
going to be a bigger size in volume
and it gets to a point where it gets
like a comically big size of volume like
a [ __ ] bucket by the end that's like
the final tier
I just I remember me and Cindy went
there and we were just like let's try
and do it let's let's try and complete
the game and it's it's I I want I want
to take someone makes that sometime just
to see like I just see like what if we
take a Brit there now what if we take a
[ __ ] take a trip like like a German
there see how far we get because we we
got to like the second to last here and
we were like [ __ ] what was the vessel
what was the vessel yeah what was the
vessel it was like um are we talking
like a boot or yeah what was it it was
you know you know when you see like some
of that like you know that comically big
wine glass that's just like oh I'm only
gonna have one glass of wine foreign
and then the final stage was just a
straight it was just like a [ __ ]
glass pocket almost like it was like
kind of like a yard basically I think
there's a few of places that do that
gimmick in Japan yeah yeah because it's
like I've been to one like that in
ropongi as well yeah um that was we
should we should do it to see out of the
three of us who can complete it I I did
beer last time I went and I think that
was a mistake because like by the I
think the second one or third one I was
really full yeah yeah
I can't drink this bucket I can't drink
out of this it's not even fun to drink
anything yeah it just becomes not fast
I'd rather have a bunch of small glasses
the way everyone has been doing for a
very long time yeah it was fun for a
one-off yeah I mean I I like going to
places where they're kind of like it's
it's they kind of just gamify something
whether it's like [ __ ] gotcha it's
like so much gotcha [ __ ] here so much
gotcha stuff in daily life yeah like
even like you go to akihabra you can
play the Sketcher machine for like 10 20
bucks yeah and you might get something
but normally you get something kind of
yeah and yeah one thing one thing I've
never understood is uh
have you ever like you know gone to like
an anime convention right and you know
they have like those special mystery
boxes yeah right yeah that's one thing
I'd like that's that's one thing I've
never gotten and I don't understand why
people would get them because do you
think they actually put like good gifts
in there so I think it originated it's a
New Year's thing in Japan right it's how
it started and they're normally actually
pretty generous right like it's meant to
be like a lot of the times you have to
book these and they're limited a lot of
the times as well like especially some
of the more expensive ones like the ones
that you have to book like some of the
stuff in these uh lucky but they're
called but like in this like there's a
lot of stuff where you can only get it
in the lucky bag like it's not sold
anywhere else it's like a special like
package but like you won't know what it
is until you get it right I got one last
time from amiami it was 500 bucks and I
definitely got more than 500 worth of
figures in the Box the Pokemon one for
example the Pokemon's in every year like
you have to book that [ __ ] like four
months Jesus I didn't realize you had to
book this year man of course yeah it's
Japan uh yeah you have to all the good
ones you have to book but you also
generally it's more like a celebratory
thing than a let's make a lot of money
it's like yeah that's that's just like
happy New Year yes happy New Year
because you know New Year's one of the
biggest things in Japan and then I think
uh you know
um when American consort they're like
money is this a money-making and ax was
always that one booth I can't remember
which one it was there was that one
where they would make the Walls World
the lucky boxes remember these yeah the
animation right there that just have a
like a booth that was made out of these
lucky boxes yeah I remember that and
dude you just they have never had
anything good enough never ever they're
good for Content that's about it even
then like move down or edited a video of
I think with uh hard on unboxing one of
them but it's just the saddest thing
ever and it was like 50 bucks nothing
nothing good in it he gave me like a
squid game plush that wouldn't shut up
there's like a tiny one yeah you press
it
whatever the [ __ ] inside yeah yeah I
was like oh my God this is so [ __ ]
it's funny oh man